[Musique]
tous les mercredis du mois de février on
vous présente mercredi air avec la
planificatrice financière 110 la
chapelle merci d'être avec nous samedi
la chapelle pour répondre à des
questions du public
alors on y va avec une question qui nous
vient de carole mongrain est ce possible
une fois à la retraite avec rendent de
l'employeur mais sans revenu d'emploi de
contribuer à notre reér ou faut-il avoir
un minimum de revenus d'emploi pour
justifier une contribution dans l'année
en cours
et si dans trois ans par exemple je
retourne au travail à temps partiel
pourrais-je recompte les bus et à
montréal pour la portion non utilisés
donc oui c'est possible de contribuer au
real même si vous êtes sans revenu
d'emploi est évidemment dans la mesure
où vous avez les liquidités pour le
faire et donc en fait ça s'explique
parce que les droits d'association sont
pas calculés seulement sur le revenu
d'emploi ou le revenu gagné de l'année
en cours mais bien sur le revenu gagné
les droits de cotisation pardon qui
aurait était inutilisée donc si on n'a
pas gagné de revenus cette année mais
qu'on a des droits qui sont inutilisés
on va trouver cette information l'eau
sur les dix cotisation fédérale
on peut cotiser même sonné sans emploi
et donc à la question savoir sedan 3-1
pour refuser son âge donc si madame en
fait un moins de 112 ans va pouvoir
comme ça sans rien la date limite c'est
le 31 décembre de la 71e année ensuite
deux sauts s'il lui reste des droits de
cotisation
elle pourra le faire dans le regard de
son conjoint si celui ci est plus gens
très bien merci beaucoup
bonne réponse michel toupin pose la
question suivante
n'ayant obtenu aucun gain en 2020
puis-je quand même déduire les frais
normalement encourus pour générer mon
revenu par exemple de nouvelles cartes
d'affaires imprimés avant le 13 mars
2020 arguin j'imagine que monsieur parle
de revenus d'entreprise puisqu'on a
convié mention cartes d'affaires donc
deux scénarios possibles soit monsieur
est incorporé ou pratiquer de façon donc
à enregistrer comme travailleur autonome
donc si vous avez plus de dépenses que
de revenus vous avez une perte dans
l'entreprise dans le cas d'une
entreprise incorporée vous allez avoir
un déficit à la fin de l'année qui va
être reportée au sol de début de
l'exercice suivant
si vous êtes travailleur autonome donc
une entreprise individuelle enregistrez
vous dans le fond pourriez avoir
inscrire une perte dans votre
déclaration de revenus au printemps donc
est généralement y est possible même
d'attribuer cette perte la à des revenus
gagnés dans les années précédentes donc
les trois années précédentes où les 20
prochains donc évidemment ça serait posé
la question là un comptable pour avoir
une réponse un peu plus technique
excellent collègue du val nous pose la
question suivante j'aimerais savoir
comment éviter à mes héritiers de payer
un maximum d'impôt lors de mon décès
mais actif maison celi réel pas de
dettes
excellente question donc la
planification successorale a toujours
été importante mais avec vous savez le
nombre de familles reconstituées c'est
très important de se poser ces questions
si donc la principale question c'est qui
sont les héritiers
parce que le jour du décès vous êtes
présumé avoir disposé de tous vos biens
la juste valeur marchande
par contre si vous faites un roulement
fiscal à votre conjoint
les impôts sont reportés au deuxième
décès donc pas d'impôts impayés
donc si le conjoint les rip sitôt
d'impôt lorsque c'est les enfants le
roulement fiscal s'applique pas il est
donc on doit calculer les impôts de
façon générale pour les résidences
principales y pas d'impôts à payer
à moins qu'on ait eu des résidences
secondaires dans le passé qu'on ait joué
avec let la désignation de résidence
principale le syli de nos rapports en
fait d'un pacte fiscal rodez si c'est
vraiment sur le reér que ça va se jouer
les impôts différés donc tout ce qui est
accumulée comme un report d'impôt dans
la vie de madame va être payé à son
décès ou être ajoutées sont la dernière
déclaration de revenus donc logiquement
si les artistes sont les enfants et le
conjoint basse comment l'on peut
recommander de rouler le reér aux
conjoints et donner les autres actifs
aux enfants par exemple ou encore
parfois on va rouler libyen aux
conjoints et faire une succession avec
l'assurance vie par exemple pour les ans
ok mais ça roule bien justement nos
maîtres d'hier et r 110 la chapelle mais
on va s'arrêter là pour aujourd'hui on
évite bien sûr les gens nous écrire
merci beaucoup pour ses réponses étaient
passés merci bien
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit